Now the work in span laws
tell you something about
the minimum possible time.
But I want you to ask yourself
a more interesting question.
Is there an upper bound on
the time to execute the DAG?
The answer is, yes,
according to a theorem by Richard Brent.
Now, I love Brent's result.
I think it's really cool and
really elegant.
Personally, I think you can get a lot
of insight into parallel algorithms
by re-deriving it.
And you can do so without a lot of work.
Now having said that, there are a bunch
of steps involved so I'm going to break
this derivation into two parts, and
we'll have a small quiz in-between.
So we have a DAG with a certain
amount of work and a particular span.
Just as a reminder,
our goal is to estimate an upper
bound on its execution time.
Now suppose I give you
a PRAM with P processors and
let's say you run the DAG.
Now let's imagine we're doing some
forensic analysis and we go back and
we look at the execution
of the DAG on the PRAM.
Let's break up that
execution into phases,
where each phase satisfies
three conditions.
The first condition is that each phase
has exactly one critical path vertex.
Note that this condition
immediately implies that there have
to be D(n) phases.
So let's say I've numbered the critical
path vertices from 1 to D(n).
Then this condition implies
that there will be D(n) phases.
So here's a cartoon of what
the phases might look like.
Now since the critical path
vertices are numbered, and
there's one critical
path vertex per phase,
then I can number the phases by
the critical path for text number.
So for
example here's critical path vertex 2 so
I'll call this phase, phase 2.
Okay, that's the first condition,
what about the second?
The second condition is that all non
critical path vertices within a phase
are independent.
Let me show you what I mean.
Let's take any phase with its single
critical path vertex, like this one.
Now consider any non critical path
vertices that have been assigned to
this phase.
These vertices can only have edges that
enter the phase or exit the phase, but
they can never depend on one another.
So for example, this is okay, but
a dependence like this
would not be allowed.
Now this condition is always
possible to satisfy, and
a good exercise is to see
if you can figure out why.
As a hint, just think about paths,
and the fact that the critical path
vertex lies on the longest path.
Now, there's a third condition which
is that every vertex has to be in
some phase, and further more it
should only be in one phase.
So suppose this is our DAG, and
let's say we've divided it into phases.
Now every phase K will have some
number of vertices associate with it.
Let's say that number is WK.
And this value WK will include
the critical path vertex.
So by this third condition,
which says that
every vertex has to appear in exactly
one phase, what does that imply?
It basically tells us if I add up
the WKs across all the phases,
then I should get the total
number of vertices.
That is, the sum of WK for
K goes from 1 to D should be W.
Okay, here's a question for you.
How long will it take
to execute phase K?
Let's call that time tK.
Now if I have WK units
of independent work,
which I get from condition two,
then that tells me that the total
time to execute phase K should
be ceiling of WK divided by P.
And that in turn implies that
if I sum over all phases then
the total time is just
the sum of these tK's.
So plugging in tK we get this summation.
Okay, I know what you're thinking,
this seems really unhelpful.
Are we any closer to achieving our goal?
Mathematically these ceilings are really
ugly, and can we make them go away?